Speaker 1: Donald Trump appeared this morning on
a program called American Sunrise on a channel
called Real America's Voice. It's as much of a
mystery to me as it is to you, but this appears
to where, a this appears to be where Donald
Trump is increasingly able to be interviewed.
And he has broken his silence after these
incriminating photos of top secret and secret
documents were published from Donald Trump's
office. And it's really, really bad. So let's
take a quick listen. Won't spend a lot of time
on it, but here is Trump weighing in, I guess.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: A lot of people think that
when you walk into my office, I have confidential
documents or whatever. It may be all declassified,
but I have confidential documents spread out
all over my floor. Floor. And like a slob,
like I'm sitting there reading these documents
all day long, or somebody else would be right.
So it is so dishonest when you look at it. And so
people were were concerned because they said, gee,
you know, that's a strange scene. You look at this
law and you see these documents. Right. They have
cover sheets of documents. No, they put them
there, John, and they put them there in a messy
fashion. And then they took a picture and they
released to the public. And this is what we're
dealing with. Who are these people?
Speaker 1: That is just the best. Now
it is completely plausible. It really is. It's
completely plausible that the documents were
displayed in that way, because that's how the FBI
sort of laid them out in order to show everything
that was there. But Trump's office is the office
of a slob. I mean, these pictures are widely,
widely available from different times
at which Trump has been interviewed.
His desk and his office are covered with papers
and stuff. So we don't know the truth of whether
Trump had the documents all over the floor or
whether they were placed there by the FBI. But
just look at pictures of Trump's office. We have
one up on the screen. There are literally papers
all over Donald Trump's desk. There are stacks
of binders and books and boxes and papers behind
Trump. It's a complete and total mess. The guy is
a slob. So when he tells you that he's not, don't
believe it. We've seen it. We know exactly what
is going on there. And the truth of, you know, did
the FBI lay out those documents are not but not
it totally plausible that the FBI did lay them out
as they do in order to take pictures of exhibits
that they need of the things that that are found.
But Trump is a slob and his office is a complete
and total mess. It's been that way for decades.